morning all it was the news we'd all
been waiting for the prime minister has
called it a
one-way road to freedom the plans for
easing as i'd have locked down over
summer have now been revealed
but how will unlocking at each stage
affect coronavare's cases
and will we end up seeing vaccine
passports being brought in to help us
get back to a more normal way of life
we'll be asking the health secretary
shortly first our chief political
correspondent john craig reports
okay so tell me a little bit more about
it boris johnson's four steps to freedom
start with children in england back to
school next month
then in al fresco april in beer gardens
pubs and restaurants opening their doors
in may
and england's lockdown restrictions
continue
until at least june we're now traveling
on a one-way
road to freedom and we can begin
safely to restart our lives and do it
with confidence
but can he guarantee no more u-turns
i can't guarantee that it's going to be
uh irreversible but the intention
is that it should be irreversible and
that's why we're going uh in the way
that we are that's why we're taking the
the steps that we are and warnings that
covet could be part of life
for years to come the vaccination will
take the rates right down
but they will not get rid of us and this
is something we have to see for the long
term
and in my view is likely to be a problem
in particular in the winter
for the next few winters it may be
necessary next winter
to have things like mass wearing in
certain situations
making sure that if we get the sorts of
symptoms that we know are associated
with kovid we stay off work
some tory mps complain the lockdown is
being lifted
too slowly today's pace of change will
be a hammer blow for aviation for pubs
for restaurants hotels gyms and pools
the arts and the establishment once
again it seems to be modeling
not data which is driving the
government's decisions
to help reopen the economy the
government is considering
whether people should have to show a
covid certificate
or vaccine passport to attend big events
like concerts
or sports fixtures mr johnson says the
end of england's lockdown is in sight is
your roadmap too cautious prime minister
but it remains a long road to freedom
john craig sky news
[Applause]
and the health secretary matt hancock
joins us once again on the program good
to see you this morning mr hancock
very big day yesterday yeah and it is a
good morning
isn't it there is i think for many
people light at the end of the tunnel um
just in terms of the road map we do
understand of course there are always
differences of opinion
around the cabinet room table different
ministers have have different emphases
this roadmap feels like it does
have an awful lot of influence from
yourself from the department of health i
mean
this is pretty much what you were
looking for wasn't it
well you would expect the department for
health to have an impact
on the road map for coming out of a
pandemic but actually there was
remarkable levels of unanimity in
government of course um you know it's
totally normal to have debates
in this case largely around the details
because we're all absolutely determined
to come out of this as fast as safely
possible
but no faster and the the safety is
important
and we're determined as the prime
minister puts it that this
should be irreversible that is the goal
and then it's then it's a judgment about
how how much we can lift at what moment
but it's not just a judgment for us it's
actually on everyone
and this is one of the points i want to
stress is that some of
you know this isn't just about choices
the government makes
it's actually about how everybody
responds and pulls together
so for now it is so important that
people stick to the existing rules
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel and the best way to get there
is for everybody to keep abiding by the
rules as they
are in very very large part and then as
we release things
we need to move at that pace because
that is the that is what we expect to be
the safe way to get out of this as fast
as we can
as we roll out the vaccine program
because all of this is
only possible because of that rollout
indeed and i want to kind of quiz you a
little bit more deeply about the
the vaccine efficacy because great data
from chris whittie yes
i think plenty of people will have stand
up straight at that point but in terms
of the
the pace of relaxation it strikes me you
heard from steve baker just a moment ago
you know he could demanding that perhaps
we could move quicker under the scheme
under the road map has announced it
doesn't look like actually there is any
scope
from moving any quicker because of that
that five-week gap between the steps
well that's right it's very very
important that we
can see the impact of one step before
taking the
next step and now there are some
there's a um there's just a vital need
to keep
watching the data and for all of us
and i mean everybody watching and the
whole of society
to stick with this plan you know we want
to be able to hit those milestones
but we'll be vigilant and watch what's
happening to make sure it's safe to make
each move and the prime minister set out
the four tests that we will
apply before announcing that each move
can go ahead
but of course we want to make the moves
at the at the dates that are set out
but it's on all of us to make sure that
we can
by continuing to follow the rules
between now and then
as the vaccine rollout continues and as
the
as the really really positive impact of
those vaccines takes effect
this is on all of us a key aspect of
this is of course
moving out on a national rather than a
regional basis do you think people like
steve baker
will ultimately accept that i understand
the rationale for it but
you know for example if we saw cases
rising in and around
london meaning that you know people in
devon and cornwall
couldn't see restrictions relaxed in
their area do you think that people
first of all in devon and cornwall would
accept that whether people in your party
would accept that
well we have we have seen actually the
the
the rates went up right across the
country and then
in this this national lockdown have been
coming down
right across the country more so than
previously actually
now there are some parts of the country
very small targeted areas where we find
new variants that we're worried about
the new variants that might not
be dealt with in the same way by the
vaccine and we've put in particular
measures in those
localized areas for instance some around
around bristol around woking
around sefton in in merseyside um
but that's the very much the exception
the goal here is that we all move
together across england and
nicolas surgeon's setting out the path
for
scotland and the welsh and north nile
irish
administrations will set out their path
but essentially
across england a national approach we
think is the right one yeah
clearly it does feel that those variants
may well be
at the stumbling point or at least the
point that they may result in the
the pause button being hit i'm just
wondering what the government's modeling
is telling us what this this kind of
road map the relaxation
will do as regards the south african
variant the brazilian variant
well the good news is that the number of
new variant cases we're finding
across the whole uk is falling and has
fallen quite sharply over the last
month um and in the last um
a week or so there were just over a
dozen
new cases which is far smaller than we
were seeing
even a couple of weeks ago so the extra
measures that we're taking at the border
are working and also the lower case rate
makes it much
less likely that there'll be new
variants here because new variants tend
to
arrive when you've got an area that's
got a very high case rate and the
virus is trying to escape from the
immunity that people are getting
naturally now we need to do continued
work
to understand how effective the vaccines
are against these new variants we now
know that the vaccines are extremely
effective
in the real world in the uk right now
against the against the main variant
here the so-called kent there and that
is what
is you know the vast vast majority of
cases here
are but we do have to protect against
these new variants
and that is a big challenge one of the
reviews announced yesterday
is a review into international travel
and that
review will be informed by the evidence
that we're currently collecting
on the impact of the vaccine on these
the so-called south africa and brazil
new variants if the vaccine works well
against
them then we can be much more relaxed
about international travel
if the vaccine doesn't work against them
then
that will be much much more difficult
just in terms of we mentioned it before
fantastic data in terms of vaccine
efficacy and
you and i spoke a few weeks ago and
there was a hint already at that point
that there was data
confirming that do we have enough
information yet on what effect the
vaccines are having on transmissibility
well the evidence published by public
health england yesterday
demonstrate that there is a reduction
of around 70 in
your chance of catching the virus and
the there's obviously link from that to
transmissibility
if you don't have them uh the virus then
you can't
easily transmit it obviously um the
and and then an even bigger impact in
terms of
death and hospitalization so these are
this is a really really good result you
know
i i had confidence that we'd get a
vaccine
i have huge confidence in the nhs to
roll out the vaccine
and it's wonderful to see the effect
of the vaccine saving lives in the uk
right now not just in a lab not just in
a trial
but the vaccines are saving lives right
now and you can see the result in the
real world data as well
because if you look at the number of
people who are dying each day
that number is falling sharply it's
actually falling
more sharply than it was even a couple
of weeks ago
so the halving rate of deaths
is accelerating and
that's despite the fact that the halving
rate of hospital admissions
is holding steady so this is real world
information showing that the vaccines
are working to save lives in the uk
right now and that obviously is
incredibly encouraging
yeah very encouraging indeed can we talk
about business and we've obviously heard
a number of times
the government stands ready to do
whatever it takes to to protect
livelihoods and businesses of course the
roadmap published
yesterday sets out our routes all the
way to the to the tail end of june
you know if i'm a small medium-sized
business owner this morning it wouldn't
be daft for me would it to assume that
furlough business rates relief is going
to be extended until the end of june as
well
well you tempt me uh no but the um
that's very much a matter for the
chancellor and it is so we could do with
hearing from
right now couldn't we now that we've had
the road map i understand the budget is
in a is in a week's time and i see you
smiling there but you know there may be
will be business owners watching this or
perhaps
not so sanguine about the fact they have
to wait another seven days to know
well look i understand that and coming
from a small business background myself
i
entirely understand the impact of this
on small businesses and it's been
devastating for some
and difficult for most and the
the level of economic support that the
government's put in is
both unprecedented and bigger than
almost anywhere else in the world
and the chancellor is going to set out
more details
next week can we dwell for a second
health secretary
the the judgment handed down by the high
court last week and and
a lot of ground has been gone over i'm
not asking you for an apology i'm not
asking whether or not
you're going to resign i do think it's
worthwhile asking but whether you
understand why there are quite so many
people concerned
about the procurement process there was
a there is an opaque
quality to it a number of contracts have
been awarded
to people that you and others within
government have personal relationships
of some form or another with
do you understand why and i get the
rationale for why you had to operate in
this way i understand your position
but do you also understand that perhaps
in the not too distant future people
would like to know
that all of those contracts have been
awarded in a proper way would you be
mine would you be
accepting of the possibility of an
independent inquiry
uh getting the transparency on your
department that a lot of people are
after
well that transparency is there so the
good news is that
um the there already has been an inquiry
into this
by the national audit office and they
published their results which found that
there wasn't a problem with any of the
individual contracts and indeed this
court case wasn't about
the individual contract also refused to
rule out criminal abuse
if i just answer the question you ask
for transparency
the only reason that people know about
these contracts is because of the
transparency rules that we rightly have
in place
and because we published all of the
details now we published them
around on average a couple of weeks late
and that's what the court case was about
but it wasn't about the substance of the
contract
because that's already been looked into
in by the national audit office
and all of them have stood up to
scrutiny now
people then say but hold on some people
you knew what contracts
well are you saying that if you know a
minister then you shouldn't be allowed
to
to have contracts so i didn't know
perhaps that but perhaps there might
need to be a little bit more scrutiny
well there's been enormous amounts of
scrutiny and as
you know as this conversation attests
and the reason that the
we can have this discussion is because
we have that transparency
uh and the contracts in question i
didn't have
uh personal involvement in the signing
of the
individual contracts but sure what i did
do
is make sure that my team were given all
the support they could
to buy ppe to save lives and you know we
as you say we have been through this and
i think you know the
the argument that i'm making is the
argument that
not only anybody in my position would
have uh
would have made and would have done but
also it's what the public expect
right they'd expect me as health
secretary to ensure my team had all the
support they possibly
the judge in the case said that the
history of these proceedings is
unedifying the land share of the blame
lies with the secretary of state lies
with you
200 000 pounds was spent on legal fees
for a case that didn't need to happen
because you could have simply said
yes we were in breach well it's
absolutely true that the case didn't
need to happen because it was
uh not a you know it hasn't had any
material impact
so you'll have to ask the people who
brought the case why they did that
um the um to get you to get you to
accept that you were in breach
as the judge said i have no doubt the
claim has speeded up compliance
but we we accept we accepted
in full that these things were published
a fortnight late that isn't in dispute
what we argued was it was we argued a
public interest defense
it's in the national interest that we
did what we did
and my team who are an amazing
group of people who worked incredibly
hard to save lives
and that's what we do in the health
department
and and sure you know if we weren't able
to put the paperwork in
on time you know in normal times of
course we put the paperwork in on time
but in the middle of a global pandemic
you don't so you can you know you can
ask me as many questions you'd like
you're not going to change my view
and if i had my time again absolutely
i'd do exactly the same thing
exactly the same thing even if it led to
this conversation
because what i care about is making sure
that people have the protection they
need
and i care deeply about the staff of the
nhs
and the staff who work in social care
and i care deeply that they have
everything they need and it was
really tough but there wasn't a national
shortage at any point
there were difficulties in individual
areas but there was never a national
shortage
and that's because of the work that my
team did and i'm very very proud of them
mr hancock i would love to keep asking
you questions unfortunately i have to
let you go uh health secretary thanks
for coming on
tom rayner joins us at once again in the
studio and tom
obviously a huge amount of work ongoing
in terms of
getting us out of all this what left out
to you well i think
matt hancock was pretty defensive not
just on that last issue around
transparency around procurement but also
defensive of the pace
of the road map that was set out
yesterday i think this is going to be a
major point of tension
with conservative back benches
particularly as things develop if things
continue to go in
the right direction potentially we're
going to see those tensions
increase but matt hancock confirmed that
for those
arguing that the government should be
able to move faster if the data
allows it the answer was pretty clear
that the five-week
gap in between the stages that were set
out is
pretty rigid that that's not going to
change and i thought what was also
revealing neil
is that right at the start of that
interview the health secretary felt the
need to stress that this was not just
about government decisions but about
individual decisions
and implying and i think in a revealing
way that
the government is now concerned that
having set out uh a program
despite all their efforts to emphasize
that these are the earliest possible
moments that things can happen
inevitably every single newspaper is
full of dates people will have been
messaging one another saying well i
think we can do this from maida whatever
i i think it was revealing that the
health secretary showed some nervousness
that actually once you start
letting your foot off the brake that
people might start taking
uh going beyond what is allowed by the
by the rules yeah uh for a date or not
date strategy there are certainly plenty
of dates in it uh tom thanks very much
indeed
let's take a closer look at the
government's proposed route out of
lockdown from the 8th of march all
schools will reopen and after school
activities will be allowed two people
can meet
in a public space like a park and care
home residents
will be allowed a regular visitor who
can hold their hand
uh the rule of six is to be reintroduced
on the 29th
allowing outdoor gatherings of six
people or
two households organized sport will
return and you will be allowed to travel
out of your local area but encouraged
to stay local domestic self-catered
holidays could be as loud as soon as
after the easter break from april the
12th
at non-essential retail also due to
reopen at this point
including hairdressers and beauticians
pubs restaurants
although they should be able to reopen
their outdoor areas public buildings
like libraries and museums along with
zoos will be able to open their doors
people might be able to sit in pubs and
restaurants if things go well from
may the 17th theaters cinemas also
reopening at this time
up to 30 people could be allowed to
attend weddings christenings
and funerals and as many as 10 000 fans
could be allowed
into football stadiums
fast forward all the way to june the
21st the government planning then
to be able to remove all legal limits on
social contact it will also review
social distancing rules
including face masks and working from
home
this road map as we've been saying only
gives the
earliest possible date for each stage a
progress is reliant on four tests which
must be met before the next step can be
taken
they are the continued success of the
vaccine program
evidence that vaccines are reducing
hospitalizations and deaths
infection rates not surging and that the
risks
don't change due to variance of concern
something we're just discussing with the
health secretary
of course some businesses in birmingham
have been closed since last
march and are worried about what the
future holds even with this
road map out of lockdown so guys becky
johnson reports
life as we knew it is still a distant
prospect
foreign holidays clubbing festivals
normality
still months away the route out of
lockdown will be slow
and cautious there will be at least five
weeks
between each step
chef in birmingham had been hoping for
better news
he now needs the new outdoor seating
area to be finished by april
because they won't be serving anyone
inside until at least the middle of may
i think anybody in the hospitality
industry would tell you the same thing
they feel like they've been
you know they've got the the short end
of the stick when they put all the
precautions in place then everything
they can do to make it
to make it code it's secure the
stillness of shuttered nightclubs is in
stark contrast to the vibrant venues
they once were
the last time dance floors were full was
last march
they'll have been closed for at least 15
months by the time we next see scenes
like these
but the fact that even included on the
list of things that could reopen
from the 21st of june gives an industry
that's been shut
for so long some optimism it has seemed
like a never-ending nightmare to be
honest
and it seemed very bleak it's been
beyond tough
and it's tested our resolve to the
absolute maximum and it's been very dark
i'm not going to lie it's it's been
tremendously crushing
disappointment too for anyone hoping for
a haircut soon
hairdressers won't be opening until at
least the 12th of april
the owner of this salon got a new puppy
to help her cope through the long winter
months
she had hoped to be back at work sooner
it feels quite far away and i think this
lockdown's been really hard
on everybody's mental health i think um
but definitely
looking forward to the 12th the sooner
the better
after so many months of restrictions
there's now
at least hope that better times are
coming
becky johnson sky news birmingham
[Applause]
a bit of breaking news now on jobs just
reaching us in the last few minutes uh
let's speak to our
uh business correspondent paul kell so
morning paul um
what are we learning this is about
employment
uh yeah these are the latest uh
employment statistics from the office
for national statistics released
this morning which show that
unemployment has risen again
in the quarter the three months between
december and february to 5.1
that's 1.3 percent higher than
a year ago and although it is down
uh 0.3 on the quarter before that so it
shows the continued
impact creeping impact on the employment
market
of the coronavirus and the protracted
shutdown that we're into now a few other
uh rather grim figures from the release
neil if i may the payroll number of
people on payrolls is down
726 000. that's fewer people
registering registered pay there are
more than 700
000 people more people unemployed than
they were before
the coronavirus outbreak and a new
statistic from the ons
this morning almost 60 percent of that
number
are people aged under 25 so a
disproportionate
impact on the young and of course many
of them learned today with the road map
that their prospects of employment in
hospitality and leisure and such like
have not improved they can't think about
these places reopening and offering them
a job
until april at the earliest
paul many thanks the former first
minister of scotland alex samant
has claimed he's been the victim of a
malicious and concerted attempt
to see him removed from public life the
claims were made in documents submitted
to the scottish government committee
investigating the handling of harassment
complaints involving mr simond
sky scotland correspondent james
matthews has the latest
there's a lot of talk you know about
bombshell evidence to be unveiled
by alex almond well this does exactly
what it says on the tin let me just
read you some of what he has put in this
submission
he says this is him talking about what
the snp and he says
members of the scottish government tried
to do to him the evidence supports a
deliberate prolonged malicious
and concerted effort amongst a range of
individuals in the government and snp
to damage my reputation even to the
extent of having me
imprisoned he points the finger at peter
morrell chief executive of the snp
and husband of nicholas sturgeon he says
that he went around
recruiting senior members of staff to
find other members of staff
to go to the police and make complaints
about him
he says other things in this written
submission he talks about a judicial
review
a legal action that he took against the
government because of their handling
over the investigation
into them he says that he reckons there
was legal advice they were going to lose
that
but for months at great expense to the
taxpayer the government
kept that action going nicola sturgeon
was involved in at least one meeting
huge cost he says the reason they strung
it out
was because they were hoping he would
get arrested first and the judicial
review and the illegality of it
would disappear behind the screen of
criminal action his arrest
and so on so very serious allegations
being made by alex salmond
in response to snp has said these are
just more assertions
in their words without a shred they say
of credible
evidence alex salmond will give evidence
to a holyrood
harassment committee on wednesday to be
followed a week later
by nicola sturgeon it will be box office
it could potentially be extremely
damaging for the snp
uh let's have a look at a couple of
today's other stories now and facebook
has announced it will restore news
content to its users in australia after
the government amended laws that would
force the platform to pay
media companies australia and facebook
have been locked in a standoff for more
than a week
as canberra pushed ahead with the
measure aimed at tech giants like
facebook and of course google
uh the wife of the notorious drug
kingpin joaquin el
chapo guthman has been arrested over her
alleged involvement in international
drug smuggling
the former beauty queen emma coronel
ispuro was a regular attendee at her
husband's trial two years ago
she was arrested at dallas airport in
northern virginia and will appear in
federal court in washington later
her 63 year old husband is currently
serving a life sentence
after he was convicted of trafficking
tons of drugs into the u.s
music streaming platforms spotify apple
and amazon will face questions in a
digital culture and media select
committee hearing today
it's the final day of evidence for the
inquiry into the economics of streaming
despite offering a global platform the
majority of proceeds from streams
rarely make it to the artists
time to see how the weather is looking
this morning isabel is standing by
the screen with the details um well i
can see quite a lot of rain over your
shoulders there that's worrying
yeah the southerly wind also making it
feel very mild it'll be a very mild 24
hours but rain really the big story so
let's take
a look at the warnings
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so for midday the met office has this
amber warning enforced for heavy rain
for central
and southern scotland where some places
could see between 80
and 120 millimeters worth of rain so
substantial amounts falling on saturated
ground bringing the threat of flooding
it's windy as well with gusts up to
about 60 maybe even 70 miles an hour for
some exposed northern and western areas
and you can see that contrast then
whilst it's wet and windy across the
north and west it's much drier and
brighter
the further south and east you go with
temperatures in london probably up to
about
14 celsius 57 fahrenheit and we keep
that contrast as we head through this
evening tonight as well the rain
easing a little bit more from ireland
and central scotland
and it's settling itself a little bit
more through cumbria lancashire and down
through wales
into the south west still gusty as well
a very mild night for all of us 10 or 11
degrees
and then that rain sits across the west
here of england and wales throughout
wednesday southeastern areas mild and
bright northwestern air is cheering up
as well
with some sunshine and as the rain
clears through the south on thursday
many more of us settle down
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you as usual let's set
remind ourselves as the latest
data we have for coronavirus in the uk
uh ten thousand
six hundred and forty one new confirmed
cases of cova 19 were recorded in the
most
recent 24-hour period a further 178
people have lost their lives within 28
days of testing positive
that brings the uk total to 120
757 and a 17.72
million first doses of the vaccine have
been administered
just a few minutes ago i was speaking
with the health secretary who had some
news about the spread of the covert
variants
the number of new variant cases were
finding across the whole uk
is falling and has fallen quite sharply
over the last
month um and in the last um
a week or so there were just over a
dozen
new cases which is far smaller than we
were seeing
even a couple of weeks ago so the extra
measures that we're taking at the border
are working uh there's a call
for more support for struggling
companies and workers during the
phased relaxation of lockdown the prime
minister has promised not to pull the
rug
from under those hardest hit by the
pandemic but has deferred details of
future economic support
to the budget we're joined now on the
programme by tony danker director
general
of the confederation of british industry
tony great to have you on this morning
and no doubt you have poured over that
60-page
road map to freedom as some have called
it very very closely indeed
what do you make of it well look
good morning i think it is definitely a
welcome step forward and it comes on the
back of some good news
medically you've just cited and also
obviously the great success of the
vaccination program
the big judgment call here was to go
slower in a more managed way
in order to avoid the stop start of
lockdowns of the last year
and i think broadly speaking business
will welcome that
i think business will also welcome by
the way schools going back first
not only is that good for our children
but it's good for the economy we learned
in the last year that great enablers of
the economy like schools being open and
transport operating
are key to economic success so i'm sure
we'll come on to talk about some of the
sectors that aren't overly
uh happy and are quite concerned this
morning but in broad terms i think it's
really a welcome step forward
well let's dive straight on into it then
tony i mean who who this morning is
waking up feeling particularly
dissatisfied
with that which they had from the pm
yeah look i think the hospitality sector
clearly
uh this is later than they would have
hoped for you have to remember these
businesses have been out for a long time
they also missed the golden quarter at
the end of last year which was hugely
important to their cash flow
i also think the aviation sector is
something we've got to watch
incredibly closely people understand i
believe
why there are travel bans in place or
airport
airport closures and bans in place and
the quarantine system
but there's a devastating impact for our
aviation sector if we don't
are a resolve that soon and look we are
going to have to wait
uh a week or ten days to find out
whether or not they're still going to
get support
so that's an unfortunate period of
anxiety for businesses
we hope they're going to be supported in
next week's budget
but i think it's really clear that for
some of them this will be
later than they would have hoped for and
we have to be attentive to that
tony we are moving from a system that's
been a system of restrictions that's
been administered on a regional to to
one that's been administered on a on a
national basis clearly the regional
approach had its had its benefits you
could target measures where they needed
to be
had its drawbacks made it very difficult
for certain parts of the country
to ever move out of lockdown what do you
remember
saying about the fact that some parts of
the country
could be in a position to open up if not
entirely then
then as close to that as possible when
when others are not
and that they're being dragged and said
is it dragged down essentially in terms
of progress
look i i think for most businesses
certainly larger businesses
uh the huge level of complexity of
regional tiering
uh was not helpful and what we still
have
is a degree of misalignment between
devolved nations and england and uh for
businesses that are national
that's obviously an added complexity or
if you're a business that operates
across the scottish english border or
the welsh english border
then there's still being not quite
enough alignment is still a complication
but i think on the whole
people will welcome the idea that
there's a national system in place at
least for england
and they'll actually want more and more
alignment through the next six to 12
months
between all the developed nations um
and tony just just finally we are all
hoping
that things return to some sense of
normality
in the not too distant future but every
business now has to build into their
models
the fact that covid19 will be
circulating in the population
for quite some time
yeah that's right look i think there's
look uh this announcement is very good
news there's an awful lot of detail
to come if you are an employer if you
are running a business first of all as
you say there's the financial support
that comes in
part two of this announcement i.e the
budget next week
there's then a whole set of workplace
guidance we need to come back to
remember the stuff about one meter or
two meters remember about whether or not
we can work from home
or we can go into the office and there's
also quite a lot to put in place
around a workplace testing regime which
has just been extended for businesses
over 50
uh employees to the end of june with the
government supporting that
but i think you're right we're going to
be in a world of workplace testing for
covid
for the next 12 months and beyond
because we'll have to keep an eye out
for new variants
so businesses this morning will have
will have pocketed last night's news
they'll have a broad framework in place
but they'll be wanting people like us to
work with the government on much more
detailed guidance for what reopening
looks like
and as you say for what living with the
virus looks like
despite a world of hopefully complete
vaccination or close to in the months
ahead
tony danke director general of the cbi
good to see you this morning thanks for
being with us
[Applause]
and we move uh straight to the shadow
chancellor uh annalise dodds
joining us in fact just a few meters
away just outside the sovereign
sentence of the palace of westminster
good to see you this morning ms dodds um
the labour party finds itself in
something of a curious situation this
morning as regards the road map there
are
there are people on the conservative
benches at steve baker a name that
that is constantly mentioned who are far
more diverged from the prime minister
than
the leader of the opposition this
morning
well we've consistently said that the
government must follow
the data that they should be listening
to scientists
around reopening and certainly it felt
like we'd seen a real change from the
prime minister yesterday that he did
seem to be focused
on that evidence we do have a number of
concerns however i would say about the
approach of government particularly the
fact that we didn't have any clarity
around business support when these
changes were announced it's the fourth
time
that has happened but in terms of having
a more gradual approach when that's
justified by the evidence yes we do
think that's sensible
just on the the assistance for business
of course your focus will very much be
on
on the budget but and of course them
some votes that you're trying to force
through today but when i spoke to the
health secretary earlier look we all
know
what is happening in terms of furlough
what what is due to happen in terms of
furlough
and in terms of rates assistance we look
at the road map and it directs us to the
end of
june surely now is the point of which
the chancellor could
legitimately preempt the budget and say
you know what guys we're going to extend
furlough
we're going to extend rates assistance i
mean what effect is
his reluctance to do so having
well the impact of this unfortunately
is being meted on to individual
businesses and many owners
just essentially saying the stress is
too much that they cannot cope
with having so much chopping and
changing and many weeks ago we called on
the chancellor
to be clear particularly around the sunk
costs
that businesses have to pay business
rates for example
must be paid whether or not a business
is in operation
and we don't have that clarity about
whether the holiday will be continued
the direct impact of that is additional
unemployment we saw that back in the
autumn
when the chancellor took so long to
decide his position on furlough
i'm really concerned that we may well
see that again because of his delays
in announcing the situation for
financial support now
so so tell us then just a little bit
more ms dodds about the votes that you
and your treasury team
colleagues are are trying to push
through today in essence
it is trying to hold the government to
account a little bit earlier than
what the date of the budget
well that's right and we really want to
have that clarity for business
as soon as possible i talked to some
individuals yesterday who were involved
in the performing arts of course the
creative
industries were a growing part of the uk
economy before this crisis they'll be
critical
for our recovery and they were saying to
me how they're looking forward to just a
week of anxiety you know yet more
worry because now they know there will
be that long period when they won't be
able to operate
yes of course a [ __ ] of light that they
may be able to be open
into the summer but until then they
don't know what the situation
will be and that really is causing as i
say that additional unemployment
we've already had the worst economic
crisis of
any major economy in the uk we cannot
afford to have these delays in
announcing economic support
last time we spoke of course we
mentioned the fact that we're not
regular clubbers it's been quite a while
since you and i have been heading the
nightclubs but
the nighttime industry has clearly huge
significance to to the british economy
is there no part of you that has slight
concern i mean if we hit all the targets
and hits all the goals
that you know before july we could see
people
congregating and sweaty drunken
nightclubs up and down the country with
the concomited effect
that might have in the r number
well i have to say that overall the
hospitality industry
worked incredibly hard to make sure that
they were sticking
to all of the public health requirements
that were set out i saw that myself
last summer when i traveled all around
the uk talking to different businesses
and it was clear they'd worked really
really hard to make sure that they were
operating
safely of course critical to this into
the future
we'll be making sure that vaccination is
rolled out at speeds that we still have
those measures in place when they need
to be there and that we have a testing
system
and a self-isolation system that works
now particularly around self-isolation
we've got very very low levels
unfortunately
of people saying that they are
self-isolating when they need to
we've been pushing government over and
over again to fix that
because unless we see people
self-isolating to the extent that they
need to
then we could see the disease continuing
to spread and obviously that could have
a very big economic impact
as well as a public health impact alex
dodge thanks for joining us this morning
thank you thank you well even with
the new road map out of lockdown there
are thousands of businesses across the
uk
facing an uncertain future at sky's
end of brady is at a bar in central
london for us this morning and it looks
like
you're about to indulge in a little bit
of the arrows ender
in a moment neil yeah we're in the
flight club here in victorian central
london
and they've been pretty much shut for
almost a year now let's bring in steve
moore who's the
founder and chief exec steve you've had
a chance to read what the prime minister
has said about reopening
what's your thoughts how are you feeling
what's good and bad isn't it i suppose
there's two parts to it i think the
major 17th announcement was a bit of a
shock and a bit of a kick to
the sector massively i think it's um
it's pretty brutal to sit so far behind
non-essential retail and especially
because
how safe all of hospitality has made it
arguably safer than retail so i think it
would have been nice to be in line with
those guys
so not so good and i think everybody's a
little bit upset about that however
the the announcement the potential
reopening of everything
um proper on the in june the 21st is is
outstanding i think and
you know that's that's pretty incredible
with the vaccine so some good some bad
how tough has it been you know locked
down you've got a venue like this
yeah it's expensive obviously for rent
and what have you but slap bang in the
heart of central london a place that is
normally
very very busy with people and customers
yeah i mean it's been brutal really i
mean like you said
for the last year we've been shut for
kind of nine months of it and i think
actually even though the fellow scheme
has been really good a lot of the
sectors really really struggled with
rent still
with again paying ni and pension
contributions all that so
so everybody's been slowly going
backwards and then obviously it's been
knocking out a fair amount of people
going into bankruptcy so for us
it's been incredibly tough but been
tough for others okay
steve we wish you the very best of luck
with uh reopening
and neil i'll tell you what when this
place reopens scotland versus ireland
let's get down here
and just bring in and just show you so
you can hire anoki
um by the hour here and it really is a
fantastic venue and i'm just gonna
just for for the morning that's in it
neil everything's slowly getting back to
reality
let's end on a high note
and uh everyone here looking forward to
may the 17th
yeah i was going to say magic darts end
about judging by your form i'll just say
well let's see what you could have won
and we'll be back to you later on in the
day
let's turn our attention to events
across the atlantic shall we
and president joe biden has led imminent
silence to honor victims of coronavares
after the country became the first in
the world to record more than half a
million deaths our u.s correspondent
cordelia lynch reports
joe biden's personal life is marked by
tragedy
now he oversees a country with more than
500
000 dead from covert 19. that's more
americans
who have died in one year in this
pandemic
than in world war 1 world war
ii and the vietnam war combined
that's more lives lost to this virus
than
any other nation on earth this is
one of the last times that i think we
were all together as a family
danny tavares has seen generations of
her family
wiped out i've lost six individuals
four uncles and a brother and
his and a half brother and his mother
and so it's it's been
it's been extremely devastating i i just
didn't see
i didn't see it coming it hasn't been
easy to cut through the grief
as a council member she's had a
community to care for
80 percent of people in her area of
prince george's county in maryland
were born abroad and they've been hit
the hardest
another diverse community in america
that continues to suffer
here a lot of people live in crowded
homes many don't have
health insurance and they work in
front-facing jobs that leave them
particularly
exposed that's led to a disproportionate
number of coded cases
and deaths denny believes the system in
the u.s
is still freezing them out to me
the fact that we don't have a
testing site in the zip code we don't
have a vaccine site
in the zip code to me speaks volumes
life expectancy fell by a full year in
the u.s in the first six months of 2020
but the gap between black and white
americans is now at
six years it's devastating
truly devastating to me as part of the
structural racism
challenges that we continue to face
cases
are going down but this white house has
a long way to climb
and it needs to move fast cordelia lynch
sky news maryland
so the uk now has a tentative plan for
coming out of lockdown abbott earlier
matt hancock told the program it's
not just about the decisions the
government makes it's how
everybody responds he said it's never
been more important
to stick to the rules uh lucy beresford
is a psychotherapist and she joins us
now from central london
morning lucy always good to have you on
the show um
let's talk a little bit about behavioral
changes that
that may well have have come as a result
of of covert 19.
how much of the way do you think that
we've been behaving in lockdown and the
the distancing and the the just the
general
fear of the outside world how much of
that is going to live with us for a long
time
well you're right to mention the fear
because it's one of the key drivers to
making behavioral change
but there is also an opposite
driver which is about being sociable
uh the pleasure principle that freud
talked about and just in general getting
out there and living your life
so those two polarities being anxious
being fearful
but also wanting to get out there will
be in tension with each other for some
time to come
and what i mean by that is that for many
people
the things that we've got used to doing
washing hands when we come in from
outside maybe or wearing a mask
on social on public transport or in a
supermarket
those things will probably continue for
quite a large number of people
because not only do they see the benefit
in it for themselves
but they also see other people doing
that behavior so we're very imitative
creatures
and we often follow and copy other
people if we see them doing something
then we feel
less embarrassed about doing it
ourselves but at the same time
i would expect that there will be such
pent-up demand
for people to reconnect to uh perhaps do
normal things like hugging people
perhaps even forming relationships have
even having babies things that have been
very difficult
when you've been separated from other
people those are going to drive a
different kind of behavior
so those two things are going to be
intentioned the whole time for the next
year at least
i mean but that's the thing i mean so
many of us have had to
suppress our baser instincts you know
through periods of lockdown you know if
we were to just to stick
within the rules i suppose the question
is how much of this is happening at the
front of my brain and how much of it is
happening
way at the back without me knowing about
it which which part of my brain is going
to be
in command come you know june the 21st
when i can do everything i want to
well quite a lot of our primitive brain
will kick in and say well hey
i think i can really have fun here but
it will also depend on whether you have
been personally affected
which may affect your fear factor
there's quite a lot of debate at the
moment
around whether boris johnson's change of
mood is as a direct result of the fact
that he went through such a traumatic
experience himself
and we know from research that our
behavior can change
almost instantaneously if we have for
example a very great shock if someone
says to you
if you don't stop smoking or if you
don't lose weight you are going to die
that can often be enough of a motivator
to actually get you to change your
behavior
otherwise different research suggests
that it takes about
two to three months to embed new
behavior
into your psyche and as i say things
like wearing a mask which
normally the brits wouldn't have done
but if you go to asia you see that
that's a fairly
typical thing to happen during the year
it could be that a lot of people
particularly have been directly affected
by covid either they've had a very
nasty physical experience of the disease
themselves
or sadly have lost a loved one their
behavior
may change much more radically uh well
lucy
i suppose we're going to see very very
soon if of course all those targets are
met
by uh the prime minister and by the
country at lucy beresford always great
to have you on
thanks for joining us this morning
now this is frankly the best bit of
picture we have had
maybe all year nasa has revealed
remarkable video
captured by the mars perseverance rover
as it actually touched down on the red
planet now the footage shows the rover
landing
this the first time the maneuver has
been seen
it landed last thursday near an ancient
river delta
to search for signs of ancient
microscopic life
as pictures from mars it's amazing time
to see how the weather is looking
isabel is here uh what have you got for
us isabel
a real contrast neil it's looking pretty
good in the southeast some mild weather
some sunshine but a very different story
elsewhere
let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
wet and windy for northern and western
areas the met office has
many warnings out for wind and rain but
the amber warnings across central and
southern scotland have real concern
where we could well see between 80 and
120 millimeters of rain falling
from midday to midday midday today to
midday tomorrow so it's getting on for
about five inches worth and that could
well lead to some flooding issues so
it really is quite a poor story then
with a strong and gusty southerly wind
gusts in excess of 60 maybe 70 miles an
hour at times for
exposed areas continuing to push this
rain northwards
and eastwards you'll find though that a
good chunk of east wales central and
eastern england stays dry though
best of the sunshine in eastern and
southeastern parts here where
temperatures will widely get up to about
13 or 14 degrees
now there will be some subtle changes
tonight the rainey is away from ireland
and central scotland but it continues to
fall across the north and west of
england and wales still pretty gusty
here
mild for all of us tonight and a really
mild start when you step out tomorrow
morning
the rain then slides away from
northumberland and cumbria but it does
continue to affect lancashire
through the peaks wales and the
southwest tomorrow but otherwise either
side of that
not bad at all definitely a brighter
picture to the north west the southeast
very mild 14 to 16
with a little sunshine now that front
tends to weaken almost all together by
the time it reaches southeastern areas
on thursday
and then high pressure builds in and we
can promise
a lovely end to the week it really does
look very nice it'll be a little bit
fresher in the early mornings as we head
into the weekend
touch of frost maybe a little fog but
otherwise a fairly settled picture on
the way
the weather sponsored by qatar airways